please welcome our good friends at
Timothy Olyphant
[Music]
I get it I get what you're doing you're
you're dressing nice you what you're
doing I see what you're doing very funny
very funny they told me he's got a
little surprise for you backstage you
can't know what it is and here we go
that's you make me look like a real dick
so that was your fun little prank cuz
you're gonna take the now the iconic
Conan look that I
and you're gonna watch you're gonna make
a fool out of me is ever gonna bawl
first of all and you know me we're
friends so you'll vouch come on we are
friends
I've always this has always been my luck
that has never been your look and and
this is your new look no no you're
you're my thing no no I'm not doing you
know I'm gone
this was my thing this is my war I just
got dressed and I brought this from home
you lie what do you like first of all
you're a huge fan of the show so you've
watched everyone in the new iteration I
know that you've seen what I'm doing on
the air and this is a sad attempt to I
think make fun of my look when all
you're doing is making me look even
cooler that the first time we I came on
your show ever many years ago if this
occurred to me the day I ran into your
wife
yeah at the restaurant here and and she
pointed out that when I saw you a few
weeks ago on your podcast you're on the
podcast yeah and she said that you
compared me to a cat chasing a laser you
were kind of all over the place people
loved it but you were all over the place
it occurred to me that the first time we
we met and I was on one of your shows
you referred to me as the cool guy yeah
and I thought wow how far we've come you
say I've gotten to know yeah yeah yeah
well and I will say we have become
friendly in real life I don't have a lot
of friends outside the show I don't I
don't something no more of my own choice
and no one liked I'll feel sorry for ya
there's a reason for it but we became we
because hard it's hard to keep Outsiders
quiet yeah but we became we became
friendly we became friendly outside the
show and what's weird is when we go
places together we make the oddest
couple and yeah I'll have commented I
know that I went that we've become such
good friends that the other night I went
to a restaurant and I got there before
the I was meeting someone there and and
the maitre d said meeting your wife and
I said no and they go
Conan that's true that's true you know
this woman you remember this this woman
came up this is a true story this way we
should we should dress alike when we go
out to be sure no this is just right
don't you think yeah all right tell me
the woman yet you're like a cat with a
laser you know it's like this we were at
a restaurant together and this woman
came up and it is yes I remember you
tell the story cuz she thought she was
complimenting us okay story first of all
going out with Conan there's a lot of
like go dad there's a lot of big like
people get excited right that's kind of
yours like if people are happy to see me
I suppose you know come on people get
very excited it's pretty
yeah yeah I don't I don't have that
problem no it's a different encounter
and it's a anyway we have you got your
hardcore fans too but they tend to tend
to get a lot of I think they confuse me
as being perhaps a cool dude that I play
on TV so I get a lot of like I see you
over there I don't want to make a big
deal I love what you're doing
and then they walk away and I'm like yes
it is good if again never get you did a
lot like people didn't like do a
[Applause]
restaurant and I'll be like the guy
would be like you might want to try the
celery soup and I'd be like yeah but
anyway that's why I'm gonna get lady it
was a class I'm so good she managed to
both compliment and offend us both in a
single moment is good she literally
walked up to our table she was so
excited to see both of us and she said
no you don't understand
she said if if I could I could have a
guy with and she reference to me with
your looks and then she looked at you
and said and your brain
she left and both of us like [ __ ] it was
literally like thank you